knee smith on the drive gets inside high  off the glass missed  tipped outside to griffin irving racing  up the floor griffin back for durant  oh oh he goes down hard over smart  and an offensive foul call well i'm  surprised durant jumped up the way he  landed doris  scaring mike  wow maybe he could have hurt a hip or  his right arm actually ends up buried  beneath him  legs taken out couldn't get his hands  down that is a  terribly frightening fall durant picks  up his first on the offensive but  apparently okay  smart calling for a clear out wants to  post up kyrie irving  and draws the foul irving's first  personal and look at smart taking the  hit  that's a good defensive play but you're  right dars i mean the way is his right  arm got caught underneath  not really able to brace the fall